we got a king under sting it will finish
it over there all right let's do it I
was well but itza from South
Johannesburg South Africa
what's up Brandon and Theo and Moritz
are coming to you from Johannesburg
South Africa big fan of you both and one
of my guy friends recently got engaged
but his girlfriend proposed to him he
said yes seems fine with it so I've got
a king it'll sting it for you girls
proposing to guys thanks a gang gang
buzz buzz cheers love oh that's
Australian running where's she from
good luck out there man South Africa's
the wild wild no that's Africa bro she's
in Africa she's not Africa she doesn't
forget the end of it but it's South
Africa dangerous all of Africa dangerous
there is elephants friction there will
say that major friction that's true you
got to deal with animals humans
everything in Africa it there's a lot of
cheetah take you to oh yeah did even one
of those strong willoughby's or whatever
those things y'all do them black water
buffalo Oh Harve bro
selling drugs I come across a [ __ ]
hippo that's what they deal with we got
gang violence out here they deal with
hippos and [ __ ] cheetahs yeah we're
complaining about mosquitoes yeah we're
complaining about a little fire on the
freeway and these people are [ __ ]
you're worried about the West Nile
that's the top virus do you know wonder
what she's saying girls proposing guys
yeah cuz i dying
so like let's just do it man he's all oh
I guess I like it I'm an indecisive male
you know I come from a long line of
indecisive males and uh I'm surprised
I'm even here you know because somebody
had to make a decision or a couple
decisions had to be made and so I think
if a woman asks I like it because then
you can say yes or no I'm a little old
fashioned you know a little old
fashioned it depends on the girl does if
it's like kind of sweet and just kind of
No you know is the right timing I guess
I'm into it but she does CrossFit and
she's like grill Balkan [ __ ]
she has calloused hands and she gets
down on her knee yeah
dude what are we doing yeah yeah I don't
want that oh no if she's like dust off
chops I talk to you for a second yeah
yeah keep them power
yeah actually jumps out of a Chevy and
gets down on a knee actually man the
more you bring it up like that like when
it gets to the actual physical act of it
it's gonna be really embarrassing she
was a full rack of ribs you got a salad
of salmon on it she's down an Anejo
dudes like what the [ __ ] is happening
yeah she carries you out sure man you
turned me out on this and brother okay
but do know you needed to talk to your
friend okay I know that there's some
exceptions
yeah there's except if you're in a coma
or something like that and your lady and
she found the ring you were gonna ask
her and you're gonna die yeah that makes
sense and that's beautiful man but yeah
she gets out of it you know truck leaves
the truck running gets a kiss yes just
to go back to work he's in part and
takes a construction hat alive sits down
on me and then jumps makan [ __ ] you
know
[Music]
dude that's a man you're talking about
it's a male but there's also if you have
an eloquent woman that like ballets over
to you and it does a pirouette and so
that's you yeah they can really cute but
yeah I don't know man
[ __ ] I quit CrossFit because it's girls
beat my ass they're just not into it man
it's not for me yeah it's not for me
there I think it would be too much I
think what do you guys think yeah what
the [ __ ] am I talking about dude no way
okay miss no way you let Oprah do it if
you're a billionaire you can do that's
the best to live that's the price dude
if you want to feel how Americans feel
about it do it at a baseball game see if
you get booed on stage you feel like hey
yeah you feel like Trump and [ __ ] le
doctors King you get booed out that
[ __ ] stadium dude dude if you're a
billionaire though the rules get
different who was and results the other
day he was talking about whenever the
president said billionaires can grab
women by the [ __ ] and how a Sony who
were complaining and he's like but
billionaires ain't asking you know no
that's what they do
yeah have you ever had a billion or grab
your [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah thousand airs
grabbing your [ __ ] like cat you would
propose to your man yeah cat you really
pretty strong my other absolutely no
absolutely no you have a snake tattoo on
your forearm and then pretend you're not
gonna propose yeah but are you gonna
email him a bunch in the middle of the
night and say proposed proposed subject
proposed also and then right in proposed
no I wouldn't email him but if I really
wanted a guy to propose I would slowly
Incept it into into one of my friends to
tell him to do it you know just like
slowly pressure over time but I'm not
proposing to any goddamn man no no wait
for him to do it yeah if you don't do it
like no you're gonna lose your chance
I'm gonna find someone else to propose
to me wow that and if I'm walking down
the aisle and you don't cry I'm walking
the bath I'm walking back I'm not gonna
run away bride situation yeah oh
your eyes when I walk up and down the
hall you might be crying because he's
you know it's over for him but still you
got to pretend it's not and so and lie
yeah right I'm just happy to be here or
you're crying cause your life is over
and they have a little stick you can get
you put the stuff in your EIN and we'll
make you cry
yeah Tom Cruise does it wow so that's
surprising yet cuz you won't do you
won't let him propose but you want him
to crime you come down the aisle
I won't propose to him you won't propose
to him right but you want him to cry be
emotional my boyfriend we're not too
emotional yeah hear me out here
stereotype agents aren't that emotional
I don't think we show emotion very often
but we are emotional I think we just
keep it in a lot of you cry behind
closed doors they cry in heaven a lot of
them that's better
they finally get up and just let it go
probably feels good oh how about oh so
good dude they are the masters of
suspense but you say exercise disguise
oh yeah maybe this guy's I guess I don't
know I don't have any we don't have
trick-or-treaters and I don't have
agents in my neighborhood I have no idea
I mean either well what else we got fans
vote on it that was just a camera sing
it okay I'm gonna say sing it do not
yeah I'm gonna go unless he's dying of
cancer and can't talk yeah or if he was
in a fire or something but if he wasn't
in a fire and nothing everything's okay
and normal I'm gonna say no
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]